this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what up wisecrack greg here have you
been hustling lately it seems like
everybody is whether you're busting your
balls at the nine to five or adding an
uber shift at night or selling your
knitted frogs on etsy the hustle is real
the culture surrounding hustling means
that rest is our last priority hustle
culture encourages us to spend our free
time pursuing money and economic
stability by any means necessary it's
the embodiment of the classic philosophy
of pulling oneself up by the bootstraps
to make ends meet especially in today's
tough economic climate but ironically
the term bootstrapping coined in the
1800s was initially intended to
reference something being literally
impossible impossible like pulling
yourself over a fence by the straps of
your boots or crossing a river by the
straps of your boots or flying to the
moon by the straps of your boots yet
today the phrase basically means you can
overcome all barriers to success through
sheer determination and hard work the
bootstraps narrative tells us that no
matter what if we work hard enough we
will eventually be successful just like
those self-made millionaires who struck
gold with just a small
one million dollar loan from their
parents and hustle culture success
stories are endlessly parroted by the
mass media often these success stories
come from celebrities using existing
social media clout to say push
diets perfumes or even stoner pottery
and while it may have worked for rihanna
most of us are in a more hopeless place
so today we're going to ask is hostile
culture a positive motivational force or
is it just a buzzword used to make us
feel bad for using our free time to
relax starting now you are a hard
heartless career gal go to work be
awesome at it and don't waste time on
foolish flights of fancy from now on you
are a robot beep bop boop or bleep let's
find out in this wisecrack edition on
hustle culture is it bad for us but
before we get into it i want to tell you
about this week's sponsor keeps keeps
makes it easier and more affordable for
guys to prevent hair loss and since two
out of three men will experience male
pattern baldness in some form by the
time they're 35 keeps is relevant to a
lot of people out there but with their
subscription service you can fight back
against hair loss and hang on to the
locks you've got the keeps process
begins with a free consultation with the
licensed keeps doctor who can help
decide which combination of fda approved
prescriptions and over-the-counter
medications are right for you these hair
loss prevention medications will arrive
at your doorstep every three months so
you won't have to set a pesky reminder
to pick up refills as your treatment
plan goes on you can message your keeps
doctor 24 7 to update them on your
progress and to ask any questions you
may have but here's one question we can
answer right off the bat while
individual results may vary it typically
takes between four and six months to
start seeing results if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com wisecrack or click the link in
the description to receive 50 off your
first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash wisecrack now back to the
show while treated like a contemporary
phenomenon hustle culture actually has
roots in the late 1800s at the time many
folks suffer from burnout that's in part
because many of them were working much
longer hours due to the advent of
electricity and the pressures of the
industrial revolution some of these
folks were even diagnosed with a medical
condition then known as neurasthenia its
symptoms were depression insomnia
fatigue and other mental and physical
ailments which we now associate with
millennial and gen z burnout but here's
the thing getting a neurasthenia
diagnosis wasn't strictly negative it
meant you were faithfully conforming to
the idealized protestant work ethic of
the time these symptoms were considered
a natural part of having an active mind
and being a good hard-working american
in fact an alternative name was
americanitis
naturally miracle cures like rexalls
american itis elixir were marketed to
the anxious patients those suffering
from americanitis were given treatment
recommendations like self-care it's like
how we're told that a few minutes of
meditation each morning will cure our
own modern americanitis still there was
one big caveat this disease wasn't for
everyone the man who coined the term
george beard believed that black and
indigenous people could not suffer from
noristhenia because they didn't overuse
their minds he thought the same about
working americans in general the
diagnosis was basically exclusive to
white middle-class americans who were
supposedly over-using their brain power
to pursue the american dream which was
all well and good but maybe a little
elixir could take the edge off right in
contrast for marginalized groups working
to the point of exhaustion wasn't seen
as a treatable condition it was an
expectation the only way of achieving
social and economic mobility this is how
the concept of the hustle emerged in
black communities the hustle wasn't an
option it was a requirement if black
folks weren't hustling they were even
stereotyped as straight up lazy there
were tons of pressure to be the model
minority miraculously succeeding in a
system rigged against you keeping up
with the hustle was and has remained a
matter of literal survival for black
americans it's only recently that the
term hustle culture has been commonly
appropriated by white people but the
timing of this particular appropriation
over recent years is interesting that's
because it coincides with diminishing
economic conditions across the board for
middle and working class people at large
today society applies the same shaming
rhetoric to practically everybody though
especially people of color if you're
cobbling together a 70-hour work week
and still not getting by well the system
isn't the problem man you're the problem
whether it's called americanitis or the
hustle working your butt off has long
been intrinsic to the american dream now
that used to mean working for the same
company your whole life rising through
the ranks and buying a home and of
course earning a retirement filled with
comfort and caribbean cruises but in
recent decades as jobs become less
secure that old school american dream
was slowly replaced by the ubiquitous
ethos of hustle culture nowadays we're
told the way to achieve true happiness
and economic freedom isn't from working
hard at one job your entire life and
climbing the corporate ladder it's from
balancing multiple jobs cultivating a
unique side hustle and maybe striking
gold on a late night dogecoin trade but
why is this all happening in the first
place that is to say when did hustle
culture become so deeply entrenched in
our society that people are getting up
at 3am to drive for uber before a full
day of work a lot of it seems to be the
result of one major shift the erosion of
labor unions which provide a means for
the working class to build collective
power since a bunch of shoemakers first
unionized in 1794 american unions have
been a way for working-class folks to
fight back against unfair working
conditions during the second industrial
revolution they achieved things like
higher pay safer conditions and shorter
work days back then unions fought
especially hard for a 40-hour work week
yet today high-profile business people
like elon musk tweet things like nobody
has ever changed the world on 40 hours a
week and silicon valley employees wear
t-shirts declaring 9-5 is for the weak
damn so what's changed union membership
has declined and dramatically in
post-war america 35 of the workforce
weren't a union in 1983 that fell to 20
and by 2020 to 11
some of this is because sectors which
had high union density have declined
says cornell professor kate
bronfenbrenner simultaneously a high
number of jobs have been created in
newer sectors like tech or unions
haven't existed before union suppression
is also rife with companies from amazon
to tesla to starbucks actively
discouraging their workers from joining
unions tech companies in silicon valley
even introduce measures like casual
dress margarita fridays and free food to
try to reduce union membership amongst
its workers but it doesn't stop at petty
attempts to please elon musk illegally
coerced employees into not joining
unions when he tweeted why pay union
dues and give up stock options for
nothing so what does this decline in
union membership say about hustle
culture well with fewer people collect
advising to demand a living wage and
better hours we have less control over
our income indeed it's no wonder that
the stagnation of wages overlaps with
the stagnation of unions instead of
focusing on the collective we're going
at it alone to try and outpace our
colleagues and climb the ladder if
working conditions are intolerable it's
not on our bosses for denying us
bathroom breaks the responsibility is on
us to manage our own stress but it's not
just the demise of unions that has
played a role in promoting hustle
culture it's also the way over-working
has been repackaged as proof of worth
hustle culture has a way of changing the
narrative from your boss is a dick from
making you work weekends two you're
doing a great job if you're working
weekends and if you're not maybe you're
just not working hard enough under the
prevailing hustle culture narrative when
we rise up the ladder due to working
overtime or multiple jobs it's not
exploitation it's a success story that's
even if the odds are stacked against you
if women are having a hard time
succeeding in the workplace they can now
girl boss their way out of it if
angelica's ever going to make it in a
male-dominated power structure she's got
to eat breathe drink and sweat
self-esteem when yahoo ceo marissa mayer
boasted of her 130 hour work weeks she
wasn't being overworked by an
understaffed company she was girl
bossing the problem is the narrative of
the girl boss takes our attention away
from systemic issues specifically the
numerous barriers that women and
especially women of color already face
in the workplace you know lower wages
discriminatory hiring and promotion
policies inadequate maternity leave and
so on instead our culture focuses on
success stories of marissa mayer
spending 18 hours a day at her desk and
then we wonder why we aren't doing that
too hustling also presents a way for
people pushed out of the traditional job
market to get by being your own boss is
presented as a way to navigate systemic
racism and other barriers to success and
both the gig economy and side hustling
have grown with digital platforms doing
casual freelance work in your free time
is easier than ever via apps like uber
lyft fiverr taskrabbit and so on in this
way recent tech has ironically helped us
move away from the utopian dream that
the technology industry preached in its
early days see the prevailing notion
used to be that innovative technology
would increase productivity so much that
we wouldn't have to work nine to five
jobs anymore hypothetically we'd all
have a lot more free time now innovative
tech just seems to find more ways to
fill our free time with more work this
is made all the more depressing by the
reality it's really hard to gain a
significant income from side hustles a
survey from bankrate found that the
average monthly earnings from a side
hustle were 686 dollars a month notably
though 49 of respondents were making
less than 200 a month the dream of
eventually earning your way out of your
day job then rarely becomes a reality
for most folks but that doesn't fully
explain why hustle culture has become so
dominant in recent years one of the
things that makes hustle culture so
appealing is the notion that by working
really hard accumulating major
achievements and earning lots of money
we will eventually become happy of
course you can't experience the joys of
high achievement and megabucks unless
you're being productive which is why
hustle culture depends on the idea of
productivity being tied to self-worth
constantly working is seen as a positive
rather than as a sign you're not being
paid enough works works going okay i
would save yeah
working hard
one of the symptoms of an approaching
nervous breakdown is the belief that
one's
work
is ever so important
that's bertrand russell huh
yes indeed yes
yes to that this leads to toxic
productivity that's where your
self-worth is so tied to your
productivity that unless you're doing
something which benefits you financially
you're wasting your time when we're
valued by how much we can achieve and
especially by how much we earn the
consequences can be devastating if we're
not making a profit we're not just
economically worthless we're literally
worthless it's no wonder then that
job-related busyness has become a status
symbol in one experiment participants
were presented with a hypothetical man
one who either worked long hours and was
really busy or one who didn't work and
enjoyed leisure time as you might guess
the busy man was considered more high
statins but what are the consequences of
this pressure to never stop working
we've all heard the uplifting slash
low-key dystopian stories of hustle
culture in action the lyft driver who
kept working while in labor the girl who
sells lemonade to fund her brain surgery
and so on there's no set answer as to
how often hustle culture actually works
a lot of it as we see from celebrities
and extremely wealthy has to do with
having existing capital to invest into
new projects or existing fame to
leverage your side hustle off of that's
not to mention being able to afford
nannies chefs cleaners and assistants to
do the tasks that normal people have to
juggle alongside their multiple jobs the
mythos of the hustle is far less
realistic if you're not already rich so
what about the rest of us well the
stress of hustling may be reducing our
lifespan increasing our risk of dying
from a stroke or heart disease and other
scary stats that you can google in the
dead of night and ironically studies
show that working these long hours and
multitasking is also reducing our
all-important productivity so we're
sacrificing our health well-being and
free time all in the name of mythical
hustle that at the end of the day
probably won't salvage our bank accounts
anyway so as hustle culture hit a state
the coronavirus pandemic was an
interesting wild card obviously it left
a lot of us working from our bedrooms
living rooms and apparently even
bathrooms this certainly had its
positives like greater accessibility for
people with disabilities and more
flexibility for all of us but we were
also expected to be even more productive
without water cooler talk to distract us
so it's no surprise that one survey
found that 68 of remote workers worked
weekends and 45
regularly did more than eight hours of
work a day in the uk remote workers have
done 33 billion dollars worth of unpaid
overtime but it's not just how hard you
work at your actual job hobbies became
commodified in the side hustles
especially in industries like
entertainment and journalism people
tried desperately to supplement lost
income from being unable to work or
losing their jobs so in some ways the
pandemic arguably exacerbated hustle
culture but on the flip side there's a
growing movement against the notion that
we have to spend our free time doing
profit-oriented work hustle culture
likes to tell us that the only reason we
exist is to make money and achieve
success the people are pushing back
against the idea arguing that
profit-minded work is not our only
purpose on this planet activists have
been promoting rest as a form of
resistance asking questions like how
will you be useless to capitalism today
books like laziness does not exist
remind us that toxic productivity isn't
good for us and that laziness might just
be a societal concept invented to make
us feel bad for enjoying our downtime
whether this movement will have an
effect on hustle culture at large
remains to be seen but what do you think
wisecrack is hustle culture a way of
motivating people to live their best
life selling knitted frogs on etsy or is
it a con designed to make us feel bad
for spending our free time watching
netflix and enjoying junk food let us
know in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for all your support check out
our side hustle by listening to our
podcast hit that subscribe button like
you're clocking in for a 12 hour day and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
rexalls american itis elixir were
marketed to those anxious patients were
marketed to those ancient to the ancient
parent anxious patients ancients
patients anxious pictures anxious
patients